et puis le Parti conservateur a présenté
son cadre financier hier les nouveaux
engagements totalisent 40 milliards de
dollars sur cinq ans notamment une
baisse d'impôts de 29 milliards de
dollars il y a beaucoup de compressions
budgétaires dans le plan qui sont prévus
les économies envisagées et les revenus
additionnels envisagés totaliseraient
près de 48 milliards sur 5 ans notamment
avec le plafonnement des dépenses une
forte déréglementation davantage de
priver en santé et moins de subventions
aux entreprises le pcq prévoit le retour
à l'équilibre budgétaire en 2024-25
on complète notre tournée en entrevue
des cadres financiers avec le Parti
conservateur du Québec jacinthe everay
les candidates du parti dans Portneuf
bonsoir madame Harel compression
budgétaire on le voit dans le cadre
financier beaucoup de déréglementation
plafonnement des dépenses publiques à
3,5 % par chaque ministère y compris la
santé c'est très peu 3,5 % pour la santé
ça veut dire quoi exactement que de
couper autant sur les services publics
en fait on coupe pas sur les services
publics on coupe sur les le gaspillage
et on coupe là où on peut faire des
économies sans couper dans les services
donc c'est bien bien sûr par exemple la
santé mais par exemple en santé on a vu
des projets pilotes qui ont eu lieu dans
la grande région de Montréal par exemple
où on a dirigé certaines chirurgies dans
des cliniques privées ou est-ce qu'il y
avait pas de liste d'attentes pas de
délai pour certaines opérations et ça
s'est avéré à être des opérations qui à
l'acte au coût donc le service coûtait
moins cher même s'il était absorbé par
la Régie de la France maladie du Québec
donc l'état peut diriger des patients
vers certaines cliniques privées qui
sont bien rodées finalement si vous
permettez l'expression avec vous on se
raconte de privé 55 ans privés publics
en santé mais en fait ça parce que c'est
beaucoup quand même les compressions que
vous proposez puis de plafonner à 3,5 %,
c'est les compressions majeures combien
d'emplois seraient perdus ah il y a pas
d'emploi qui vont être perdus
ce qui est important de comprendre c'est
vraiment il y a plusieurs économies
qu'on peut faire en faisant les choses
autrement en faisant les choses mieux
par exemple on peut penser puis ça c'est
quelque chose que la carte parlait en
2018 de décloisonner les professions et
de s'assurer finalement que chaque
professionnel la santé puisse intervenir
au maximum de ses compétences et de ses
capacités va coûter éventuellement moins
cher à l'État et ça les gouvernements en
parlent toujours lorsqu'ils sont en
période électorale mais quand une fois
ils sont une fois qu'ils sont au pouvoir
ne font pas ce qui avait promis de faire
et on se retrouve avec un système de
santé qui coûte beaucoup trop cher donc
vous vous coupez 30 milliards vous
coupez vous coupez partout finalement
vous coupez dans les la croissance des
dépenses de l'État mais les services
publics ne sont pas touchés il y a pas
d'emploi perdus comme par Monsieur en
fait là il faut comprendre que et ça je
parlerai pas chinois pour personnes les
gens qui sont à la maison le savent on a
tous des gens dans notre famille qui
sont fonctionnaires qui travaillent dans
la fonction publique et qui sont en
mesure de témoigner que il y a du
gaspillage de fonds publics on utilise
également il y a beaucoup oui
effectivement il y a beaucoup de
préjugés mais il y a du gaspillage réel
qui se qui s'effectue au quotidien les
gens sont en mesure de le concevoir
quand il parle avec les gens dans la
fonction publique et il y a moyen
finalement de pas s'abrer du tout dans
les services mais de faire mieux les
choses de les faire autrement 50 000
employés je pense en service public j'y
vais de mémoire vous voulez qu'il y ait
moins d'employés dans service public en
fait ce qu'on n'en veut pas qu'il y ait
moins d'employés un service public on
veut faire les choses de façon plus
efficace de façon plus performante on
parle beaucoup d'amélioration continue
dans nos organisations c'est ce sont des
amélioration continue on le voit dans le
service privé on en parle de plus en
plus dans nos organisations publiques
maintenant il est temps de regarder les
processus et de s'assurer qu'ils sont
efficaces et qu'on a pas de perte
finalement dans nos processus de perte
de ressources humaines et financière
dans votre plan et dans le cadre
financier vous dites qu'on va ajouter 1%
aux revenus vous ajoutez en fait dans
votre cas de financier 1% aux revenus et
vous enlevez 1% aux dépenses pourquoi il
y a un cadre pré électorat il y a un
rapport pré électoral pourquoi vous
prenez les chiffres qui font votre
affaire en mettant plus un pour cent
d'un côté puis moins 1% de l'autre parce
qu'on est on est en mesure de réaliser
que il y a des gaspillages dans notre
fonction publique et que on peut
réellement faire une différence quand on
utilise le portefeuille public et que on
en est on en fait une responsable en ce
moment
on utilise le portefeuille commun le
portefeuille des Québécois global comme
si c'est pas notre argent comme si ça
nous affecte pas mais dans les faits le
contribuable donne plus que 50 % de son
salaire en impôts en taxe et ça cet
argent-là est administré comme si c'est
pas notre argent alors nous ce qu'on
veut faire c'est de s'assurer que on
gère ce portefeuille collectif là en
étant conscient que ça vienne nos poches
en étant conscient comme un moment donné
la machine on doit arrêter de
l'engraisser sans se poser des questions
et on doit s'assurer que cette
machine-là reste efficace reste
performante et en ce moment on est en
mesure de constater que la on le sait en
santé est-ce que notre machine est
efficace et performante en santé elle
n'est pas efficace et performante à bien
des égards donc l'économie vous voulez
vraiment
exploiter les hydrocarbures donc du
pétrole il y a du pétrole à l'identique
aussi
non l'île d'Anticosti c'est un projet
c'est un projet qui a été qui était
arrêté et on n'a pas l'intention de le
remettre sur la table on a du gaz
naturel en grande quantité au Québec
fractionnement hydraulique dans la
vallée du Saint-Laurent avec avec du gaz
de schiste dans la vallée du
Saint-Laurent en fait chaque projet
devra être regardé et on ira jamais de
l'avant avec un projet s'il y a pas
d'acceptabilité sociale alors on va les
regarder un par un monsieur Fillon il
faut prendre le temps de regarder chaque
projet parce que dès 2024 il y a des
sommes là ça rentre par centaines de
millions dans votre cas de financier le
gaz de schiste pas le gaz de schiste
l'exploitation de nos ressources
naturelles de quelle façon ça va on est
dans la vallée du Saint-Laurent
sud de la vallée du Saint-Laurent on est
donc on n'est pas dans le fleuve
Saint-Laurent
de la vallée
où les gens avaient rejeté la
fracturation hydraulique en fait chaque
projet devrait être regardé dans son sa
globalité avec les communautés qui
seront touchées et on sera en mesure de
déterminer pour chaque projet est-ce
qu'il y a l'acceptabilité sociale mais
jamais nous n'irons de l'avant avec un
projet qui a pas l'acceptabilité sociale
je ne vois pas d'évaluation de l'effet
économique de toutes les compressions
dans votre cadre financier c'est un gros
changement que vous proposer mais j'ai
l'impression que vous sous-estimez
l'effet économique que ça peut avoir
négatif mais en fait on est le seul
parti politique qui prend en charge le
budget de façon responsable de façon
pragmatique et de façon respectueuse des
générations futures on est le seul parti
politique qui n'ira pas pigé dans le
fond des générations et qui n'ira pas
empirer notre dette nous on propose un
plan qui arrive à l'équilibre budgétaire
dans deux ans et on a creusera pas un
déficit on est la seule formation
politique que cette proposition là alors
il est temps un moment donné qu'on
arrête de faire des promesses
électorales juste pour gagner des votes
à court terme on a une vision à long
terme de notre économie bien reçu
mesdames merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci beaucoup